when did some bodybuilding that's my new
thing that I mentioned that no I'm not
doing this all this crazy like this what
you should then put some on to Edwards
as dick you know man I'm doing I'm doing
[ __ ] I'm doing isolating my muscle
the belly of the muscle not the Tenon's
and I'm gonna get thick I'm doing a
bodybuilding check that's what I'm doing
worked out with my boy Justin DS who
helped me out he's a [ __ ] high level
coach and he was just like here you go
just listen him on chest where's a
better chest you're been asking go well
she bends just yeah well his body looks
like it's so funny for a guy's been
wrestling training his whole life and he
looks some guys just genetically looks
somewhat soft it's hilarious he just
does ultimate dad one room now I now
Robbie lawless body looks better than
ever I know look at that dad bot I'm a
powerful dead well he just has not a dad
body by the best grappler in the world
but what I was is so ridiculous right
but I mean that's it that but Robbie
Lawler looks better than ever Italy
great what is it what is it about a dude
like that in his brain that he just
loves to fight that much a stone-cold
killer just the ultimate [ __ ] badass
Oh quite some time he's been doing it
forever since he was 17 he's just that's
he's just another day but been asking I
was talking about it was so interesting
he said you when you become when people
say you know when I was talking about
wrestling t1 or going to American
University they you would guys well like
like I technically I went to American
and I was gonna try out for the team but
I'd beaten their starter in my way
classes in high school but when you talk
about this level of wrestling like with
the air University of Arizona where
everybody was undefeated in high school
everybody's an all-star and then those
guys wrestle each other and he's just
metal sharpening metal and that kind of
training I would imagine that kind of d1
wrestling training is way harder than
hell having a hard one I bought in the
correlation between you never wrestling
in college and Ben Askren I'm saying to
you did any any even even though my fact
that I talk about wrestling is like it's
not the same thing as I just shut up
about it because that level of wrestling
and that kind of debt
is there's d1 wrestling and then there's
d1 wrestling right and I feel like yeah
I didn't either I did I'm saying I'm
saying that's why I that's why when I
even you make in your roots that's my
point was my boys'll there it's my point
there's no point there's no jumping
point but I've just at times I've been
like well I went to a d1 school right
like oh we good in high school like it's
like you didn't go
you didn't wrestle there's no there's no
story well the story is you never really
applied myself over so it's d1 wrestling
the the regimen that you go through in
college Hart much harder than what do
you want football just there physically
just different physically it's different
it's not it's not you wouldn't say it's
physically more demanding though I mean
stuff I'm not wrestling's as tough as it
gets you know this dude yeah you just do
me a favor moving forward they'll never
compare your wrestling experience in
college which doesn't exist right to the
Nazca really so I can't do that so
strange
no but I was also there big way more so
I did some takedowns now I bounced
wrestling called Sandman guys is there a
difference guys like when I was in
college well there's d1 schools and then
there's d1 schools you know what I'm
saying I mean I did the African like
those Dutch dudes like I we were on
Safari and and this is in this is in
celery and it's early in the morning and
my brother-in-law is a big strong swede
pro athlete like I'm not am NOT a [ __ ]
at all my dad ex-marine big guy and and
then of course myself the the basically
the man girl and and everybody and the
other people dude we were I was wearing
my dad was wearing a down jacket I was
wearing like three layers and I was cold
in the head I took one of the blankets
and put it on my legs because it in the
morning in Africa it's called a [ __ ]
right I'm not we're and we're driving in
a Jeep
the dude the African guy the giant
Dutchman they're the Samoans of Europe
they're [ __ ] huge he's in shorts and
a t-shirt and flip-flops
and at one point I look at my father go
how is this guy not called how is it not
called I said my brother I was from
Sweden who can deal with the Congo he's
not cold he goes hey they were just
shaking their head I go why are you not
cold any goes because it's not cold yeah
that's that's why right because it's not
cold cuz it's not that was it like there
there a rough
that's cab was these dudes and you know
say what you want and also remember like
some of these guys are like 50 oh yeah
50 plus years old and they are out there
in Borno State in madhu Guri they live
going after Boko Haram probably live for
it you want you that close the flame you
know you you I'm sure you have some of
that you know there's there's it there's
that I mean come on it's hard to when
you're living a civilian life and you're
getting your coffee from a dude with a
nose ring and everything is so safe
after you've lived that close to the
flame it's must be very difficult
because everything else is boring right
well it's not just that I mean I think
you can stand up comic yeah I don't know
I think we run into this [ __ ] just by a
big virtue of being here in this town
yeah
all the time I remember what I like yeah
when I first arrived here yeah I was
still driving my 97 4runner which is
like the first car I had in the team's
like great car still have it right it's
my surf car throw my boards in the back
and I I pulled up like on a date to meet
a girl at Chateau Marmont and like the
valet gave me like so much [ __ ] like
basically wouldn't take my car or even
talked to me I didn't know anything I'd
know like the Maury nothing nothing and
I visible I was like [ __ ] I have
killed better men than you take this car
much a juice yesterday looks like real
green juice oh boy bro
oh you got a little sick E you have a
little sick I don't know what's going on
I feel fine that's it here yeah feels
like I'm losing my voice yeah you're
getting that chest cold that feels fine
I'm putting my family a frank grillo all
my boys I feel fine though
yeah maybe yeah hopefully not I got a
busy day and night um but I drank a
bunch of green juice dude when I say I
had diarrhea would be an understatement
yeah it was even diarrhea it was just
wanna know I did that I did - it was it
I was like nothing I've ever experienced
I did two leaves that decided to play
tennis
oh wow yeah I looked at my buddies you
may go I think I shat shat myself so I'm
gonna have to stop now because I my
underwear it looked like I didn't know
what to do I didn't know what to do
seaweed in my poop in my panties
chocolate milk you had chocolate milk I
had seaweed I look like I made poopoo
steve is very strange
seaweed poopoo yeah yeah I don't know
man yeah that'll squirt right at you
you're you're rumpert you cannot enter
in oh my ass is chapped
you know the sphincter is the most
incredible muscle in the body because it
can hold water and it can hold solid and
it can kind of tell the difference how
about that and gasps oh this oh yeah
dude I spent a lot of time in like
Culiacan which is the capital of Sinaloa
which is headquarters of the Sinaloa
Federation [ __ ] largest drug cartel
in the world
what yeah yeah I made in that Peruvian
documentary there I made cocaine in a
clandestine lab in Lima oh yeah looks
that up I looked up what it takes to
make cocaine that's a multi-tiered
process took all night music oh yeah the
guy who was cooking it like the the
Cucina like the the cook guy in the
kitchen said like if people knew how I
made cocaine they would never
okay yeah so so you because I always I
want to hear all about this guy I wrote
this joke about how people like only
drink single sourced coffee you know
because they want to respect the farmer
yeah and I'm like I only do locally
sourced cocaine because there's so much
murderer they don't have a labor union
yeah a lot of blood in that cook it's
like a Blood Diamond you don't like a
blood that so if you're doing below a
lot you know and you really care about
the world you might be you might be the
ultimate hypocrite I don't know if I'm
right about that but I might be I just
think I just think there's a market for
conflict free coke yeah that's amazing
yeah
yeah I gotta write that a real hard Rob
you know it's wait life gets a man
listen this is True Grit Monday it's
true grit Monday take it easy and and
you [ __ ] walk in with your tangerine
shoes
oh it's [ __ ] I pushed you against the
wall because of I didn't do [ __ ] what
you didn't let me let me tell you
something I'm fired up dude you find me
ok your foot you're making Luke Perry's
thing about you I'm not making about me
at all dude I'm sorry about Luke but
it's it's also true grit call mr. Monday
call mr. Perry you [ __ ] call him call me
soon a call Mr Perry's used it's inhered
[ __ ] sorry
well I can't believe you didn't start
this with a salute to Diego Sanchez Oh
14 years in the Octagon 14 [ __ ] years
and still winning I got this for that
guy salute he took he took mickey goblet
on the ground and [ __ ] just beat I
don't but don't salute like this look
you're here like [ __ ] know you're here
lines back here so it's like this don't
try with my hands should do like this
this is for old guys out there you got
to be careful though because the old
guys know look what's this this is for
us old guys look but if you go too high
what's this oh well that's no don't do
that well I know but that's what you
just did no cuz that's that's black
power and then that's why Pat I know so
when you salute like this be careful
okay no one leaves my hairline it's like
they're right you got to do this well
it's also known as the mom you don't
want to do that right well with your
hairline it should be that well don't
damn I don't have a Nazi - oh you're
going down you're going down there's
this Nazi so True Grit we got look Luke
Perry was gritty but Diego Sanchez call
him a heartthrob dude it's a gift